okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel
today i have my morning coffee thoughts
so
before i start don't forget like the
video subscribe to the channel also i do
like a third of these videos on
my membership so if you want to have all
of my morning coffee thoughts that
aren't always posted sign up for my
memberships it's under i think the 10 a
month tier we also have some vlogs so
anyways that's that's my quick plug but
today
i'm going to talk about
what i always know
when someone doesn't have a good
argument they'll go for my looks
and that's the one thing i'm not really
big into like i think women have it
pretty good
pretty easy to be honest but i will say
that's like the one thing men are so
quick to do women do it too but men
are so quick too the second they don't
agree with you they'll go
for your looks
and see i'm lucky because i have a
really good relationship with my dad and
when i first got on the internet
this is before youtube like on tick tock
a couple years ago i would tell my dad i
feel like dad they all like tell me i'm
ugly and i'd be like thanks a lot dad
cause i got your jeans and for mom like
like what can you you guys made me hot
or something like that
and he's like who cares you just gotta
find one person that finds you
attractive
i think i'm getting sick sorry guys but
i'm just like well
he's like who cares what they think and
he's like half of your problems are just
worrying about like what other people
think
and i was like huh
and comparing and that's what he would
tell me too like half the time
people get upset or like mad in life
it's always about like comparing to
other people so
even the manosphere i see it right like
you know you got to be this tall or this
this much money whatever like
and this is what i've always been the
type like i just work hard and hope good
things happen
but
there's a lot of [ __ ] like out of your
control
so
are they weird but i always know
i'm winning an argument or they don't
have
much else to say if that's what they're
gonna go for because
okay you don't find me attractive so and
what anyways
um
like there's this one girl
oh my god
yeah oh my god she
it was so funny because she
she insults me for my looks right i'm
like it's always in my comment section
and so i'm i'm on like if you if you
punch me first i'm gonna punch back so
i'm like look if you've been ran through
just say that just say that it was like
a body count debate something like that
and
then my followers start going after her
for her butt like and they're like
where's your butt your butt's flat dude
she actually she's pretty and
then she's mad that they're going after
her for her looks i'm like bam
man this is what
whatever anyways
point is this point is this
they don't have anything else to attack
because they don't have any facts data
or stats
so
i don't know i got lucky i love my dad
maybe i got her oh gosh we're so close
um
what other coffee thoughts do i have
so comparisons of fifa joy
um
i think that
long-term
fulfillment comes from like close
personal friends and family
i think it's like exciting to have a new
friend
but
what comes from like
fulfillment it's like long long time
personal friends
and i've also noticed like
i think some distance is required
to have good relationships i think if
anyone's around each other too much
they'll drive each other nuts
but not as much distance as i have for
my family
i miss you guys
but
other than that guys things are going
good
channel's been growing a lot
um i've had some crazy comments and
crazy
people you know trying to
talk [ __ ] but i don't really care
because
i'm just chilling in london
season's gonna start again in the fall
you already know i'm playing volleyball
so
yeah
oh i might
school's going bad i'll say that you
guys this channel has distracted me from
my master's degree i could i could play
that i have a phd right now that kevin
samuels used to play
my dad also
used to
always would tell me that
work ethic beats smarts
and this is something i didn't believe
him for a very long time because when i
was a kid
i
i was a year young for my grade so i
graduated high school when i was 17 and
i graduated
college when i was 21. i did do a super
senior year of like i'm not the most
educated person that doesn't want to be
educated like i have a market research
certification because i wanted to play
basketball
so i did i did an extra year but um
yeah when i was in like third grade
man i was probably doing that maybe
seventh grade um i was struggling with
math and my my dad my mom isn't good at
math so my dad was always the one that
taught me math and science and that's
just not not my thing i've always been a
creative english writing like that was
more
me
and
my
so we're in the car and i'm just like
basically crying because
because i could not do this stupid
assignment and i just couldn't figure it
out i was so frustrated
and my dad said you know it's okay you
work hard you've always been a hard
worker like hard work beats talent in
the long run and i'm like that's easy
for you to say dad you went to the
university of chicago like you've always
been smart and that's the thing like
being a year young in school i always
felt really stupid
like i i honestly i felt really dumb my
whole life
to be honest
um because one i it takes me a while to
like process things
um
like i think
there's like
i don't want to say that i have a
processing disorder because i've never
like
been diagnosed with one officially and i
i was going to do it a couple years ago
just because i wanted to see but when i
when i looked up like auditory
processing
um i've never
heard something that
like articulated so well something that
like i've not been able to do my whole
life so like
like for example they talk about people
would say what and then understand what
they said a couple seconds later i don't
know if i have a disorder but i just
know i have trouble with that
um
so like sometimes it just takes me a sec
like
one
feedback that i've always gotten from
bosses is that it like
at first they think i'm dumb but then
they see like i'm actually pretty smart
it just takes me a second so it's like
it'll take me a second to learn the
initial thing and then once i once i get
it then i'm like really fast at learning
so it's kind of like
you know
i don't know but
um
so
what was i talking about
so
again i always felt really dumb
and
my my dad said you know life is long and
people can't catch up with hard work
so if you're willing to work hard like
like talent only takes you through the
first like 22 years of life
and
you're like what are you gonna do you're
gonna live to be
70 80. like the second the second half
of life is all about work ethic and you
know being smart plays into it but
it's not the end-all be-all
and the older i get the more true i i i
understand what he was saying because i
see people from like
my high school and even just
body-wise right
i know i know i gotta stop drinking
these but stop stop telling me but
but like
a lot of my friends from high school
that didn't work hard and didn't have
like discipline like they're fat now
and like i'm i'm in better shape than
pretty much all of my friends from like
high school
so
and like the thing is in high school
like eating like didn't come naturally
like i've been the same way i am right
now that i since high school
but in high school
you know that's kind of big so
i don't know if i'm making
i'm always tired when i do these i don't
even know what i'm saying half the time
but
i don't know that's that's the thing is
hard work beats talent
unless the talent's working equally as
hard but like i found there aren't many
people i can't outwork and this i found
this in sports too like at my club in
high school i started on the bottom team
and there's three teams i didn't play on
the third team and then by my senior
year i was on the first team starting
and
i i've just found in life like they're
when i'm really passionate about
something like you cannot work me
for the most part
anyone streaming six days a week i can't
do that there's a limit
but i would i would
no don't tempt me i do film something
pretty much every day but this is just
how i think so
i don't know guys work hard build
something cool
let me know in the comments what you
want me to talk about next my next
morning coffee thought
and i'll talk to you next time bye